[Music]
measure the one the most fascinating
things or what everybody what soon as
they can call always wanting to find out
what's hidden what's that side my name's
Adrian Fisher I live in Dorset in
England and I create mazes and hundreds
all over the world well I spent the
first few years of my career in
accountancy there came a moment when I'd
created amazing my father's garden and
then I started building one and two more
and so on and then I suddenly realised
this is going to be far more fulfilling
if I spent my life creating majors this
is the site of the closest is 40 meters
in diameter and Moses going here over
the years of creative mazes in some 40
countries and I guess I've built over
700 full-sized measures in the landscape
I think a maze design is a very easy
tarek art you sketch out ideas and
develop ideas on paper which drawings
but one of the exciting things is
amazing the network now a maze is a
special kind of network where I decide
there's only one start point I decide
where the finish is and I make sure that
every single bit of it can be as
confusing or as easy as I wish I'm
trying to make it as ingenious and
tricky as possible but in the end I'm
also an entertainer I like to leave
clues that help you solve it and you
feel so good about yourself when you
have beaten the maze designer like a
good movie we get to the end on this
tool you don't want it to stop I'm
appealing to some basic instincts all
that want to be entertained and explore
and amazing ideal way of doing that
its purpose is totally to 1/5 of normal
sensible practical things in life but
gives so much pleasure to send minions
you
[Music]